[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
Kos and today I'm gonna bring you one of
my best villains for spider-man I think
he came along at a time where we
actually needed him to be honest with
you I give you the day the Hobgoblin the
one-tenth scale budget line Hobgoblin
now um a lot of people don't like to
collect one-time skill you know like the
so called hardcore
statue guys and I felt that the budget
line that iron Studios has provided is
economy friendly and it allows you to
show your fandom you can add a whole lot
more statues to your collection
that's that statue was $1,000 right you
would've got one Hobgoblin for $1,000 he
said a one-third scale on a Premium
Format scale right anywhere from six six
hundred to a thousand dollars but in
that same breath if you get if you
collect one time scale you can add
anywhere from eight to ten different
characters so I feel that the budget
line actually helps it also save space
so I believe iron Studios has found the
happy medium that allows every form of
collector to participate and
participation is the key you don't want
to eliminate any potential consumers
from your product and I think they found
the niche and I think they actually
on pace to deliver a fantastic line
so this Hobgoblin has been on sideshows
ledger for a minute they didn't deliver
it for whatever reason i pre-ordered
this Hobgoblin before I even pre-ordered
its companion piece the Ghost Rider
the Danny ketch Ghost Rider so as you
can see there right there I'll show you
a couple of pictures of them together
these pictures will not be at the end of
the statue of this conversation it will
you know where I show the videos and the
unboxing and the pictures that won't be
there because it's all about the
Hobgoblin and if you want to see that
Ghost Rider statue then I suggest you go
look at my one term scale Ghost Rider
for my own Studios that I posted a while
ago but you can go to Lords of gaming
net and it's there for sure definitely
so let's get into a little history of
the Hobgoblin because a lot of people
don't know who's the Hobgoblin where
he's come from
what's the circumstances and how did he
just come to be so I think it was a time
in spider-man's law in his history where
he got to a low you know he got a fort
Kraven the hunter he done fought electro
you don't fought the Green Goblin
so they actually killed the Green Goblin
off but Marvel needed this villain to
fill that void and I always thought the
pumpkin colors that he had the purple I
mean the blue and the orange actually is
a little bit better than the green and
the purple from the Green Goblin in my
opinion I always liked the Hobgoblin a
little bit better because I guess the
mystery that went along with the
character because his his little story
right and it's always shrouded in super
mystery well you saw this one henchman
that was running away from spider-man
and he stumbled upon one of the stash
houses of the Green Goblin
so this mysterious figure he reports
back to this mysterious figure who's his
boss so the mysterious figure saw the
the green Goblin's van the green
Goblin's clothes all his bombs and his
his chemicals and all that stuff and he
decided to get rid of his henchmen so he
kills his henchmen takes over all this -
blows up the the stash house and
relocates all the stuff to a different
location now that was in amazing
spider-man 238 I believe right this
issue this issue right here and then he
was fully seen and issued 239 john
romita jr. is by far one of my greatest
artists you know I have a short list of
artists that I actually believed that
they artwork on impeccable and I would
actually run out and buy if I know that
they're drawing in the issues I would
definitely get them you know a lot of
times they say the inker has the last
word this is true but John Romita style
is so bold so brash so out there he did
so many splash pages and he was
synonymous with spider-man for me
growing up that anything that he drew
was fantastic so lo and behold John
Romita Jr has his fingers and it has his
pulse on the hobgoblin so he reworked
the dis mysterious figure reworks the
green Goblin's gear and his clothing
everything right and now he debuts as
the Hobgoblin he attacks spider-man he
gets soundly defeated and because the
Green Goblin always had that goblin
serum that made him strong but the same
goblin serum made him insane so now the
Hobgoblin goes back we works to serum so
it eliminates the part that makes him
insane but it just makes them strong
fight spider-man again and they have
epic battles this goes on for a decade
almost that we don't know who the
Hobgoblin is you know he comes back and
forth and every time we think we know we
it is because for a long time I thought
it was Ned
a reporter for The Daily Bugle I thought
they were thought it was Ned Leeds and
because it was all set up that way but
no wasn't it was a Kingsley Roderick
Kingsley fashion designer some throwaway
character that you would have never
guessed you could have you could have
never guessed that in a million years I
don't care what anybody say I think was
actually a cop-out to be honest with you
but nonetheless Roderick Kingsley is the
original Hobgoblin now I'm not going to
go into demo goblin and all that other
stuff that Marvel did with the character
later on whenever they come out with a
statue if I actually purchase the statue
I will do an unboxing I was doing
unveiling and I will talk about it but
here today we're here to talk about the
one temp scale budget line Hobgoblin I'm
so enthusiastic to have this statue
because I want to start a spider-man
line and I only have one of the
spider-man statue and to be honest there
is not truly a statue probably with the
2099 Spider Man to be honest with you
that was my favorite spider-man actually
the costume I thought it transcended and
it actually stuck for a while so then
you have classic spider-man so it's
different ones that you can choose from
that you want to get into the symbiote
spider-man and stuff like that but who
you going to pair him with but Hobgoblin
is probably my tops when it comes to a
villain for spider-man it was just an
offbeat take off of the Green Goblin a
little bit different he had purpose he
was a little bit more sinister he had
his faculties and in place so it made it
you know a nice thing so just one tough
budget line Hobgoblin by audience
Studios is a marvel to behold in such a
small package they say big things come
in small packages and this is so true
this statue is definitely well worth 125
dollars that it was to get the statue I
think was shipping was like 12 bucks
something very nice something affordable
and it allows you to have
this statue with the smoke coming out of
the bottom and he's on his Hobgoblin
cycle and he has his pumpkin in his hand
with his outstretched finger like he's a
prince Spider Man and he has that same
maniacal face they definitely did it a
hundred percent you can see the level of
detail the chainmail on his pants and
his arms and sleeves he has his pouch
this is a well-thought-out piece you can
see the glider the glider is
meticulously done it's a very nice
statue and it's something that if you
are Hobgoblin fan or you're spider-man
fan and you don't happen to have the
Hobgoblin something that you can look at
and look into and maybe possibly
purchase well this is the part of the
video where I'm going to tell you like
follow and subscribe and don't forget to
hit that join button down at the bottom
baby hit that join button I love saying
it because now we got the joint button
in the joint button allows you so many
other things once you watch iron lord
podcasts Sundays at 11 a.m. and 1 p.m.
after football season guess we bent the
knee for a football season it's almost
over when the playoff starts we go right
back to our overtime that's right I am
lost I'm 1:00 p.m. Sundays standard east
in time and you can go to the Lord as a
game of Garnett we have terms of opinion
pieces a lot of news articles hard
gaming reviews when Lord addict the last
word we're loyal Cognito and ebon tests
and also kos with this boy right here
King David also combat talked with the
king for those fights MMA that mixed
martial arts baby we got all that stuff
there for you check it out also go to
our teespring store we have incredible
clothing lines there for you guys to
check out stuff and soon maybe you know
I might auction off a statue I don't
know send the money to charity something
good something nice but this is the part
where I got to go see you next week
stick around watch the video we have
tons of video with pitches
this statue in all its glory see you
next week and always stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]